I stop and stare
at a large Stone spiral
it's on top of a Lookout Point in Tilden
Park
it's one of those places along the ridge
where the world opens up in front of you
like a picture book
across the wind ruffled Bay to the West
the Golden Gate Bridge still stands
one of the few historical artifacts
outside the city's gleaming walls
of course the bridge no longer serves
the purpose for which it was built
now it's primarily a wildlife Crossing
for wolves Grizzlies and Antelope
when I stroll when I stroll across the
Golden Gate I Try To See It Through The
Eyes of my great grandmother
gran
she used to commute past this exact
point in bumper to bumper traffic
[Music]
Grand loved this city
but she hardly could have imagined the
single vast
tree-like structure that we all live in
it rises from what was was once the
Fillmore District
that's base reaching from Pacific
Heights to Civic Center to hate Ashbury
glass steel cement
laminated graphene
and Living Wood twist into across and
around each other like a thick bundle of
rope
higher up the main trunk of this
City development
splits into narrower and narrower
branches
each branch contains thousands of
apartments
built into this structure
there are also schools hospitals and
restaurants
it's all contained in the structure
narrow pedestrian Bridges Arc from
Branch to branch
birds and drones darts through the
tangle
I think modern San Francisco would
surprise any visitor from the 21st
century
but I think what would surprise Grand
the most is what's not there
she'd failed to find the once bustling
Ferry Building and even Sausalito where
she grew up
I begin to walk the spiral
a breeze blows across the ridge
can you believe that in my 140 years on
this blue-green marble of a planet that
I never once left the bay oh I've had
plenty of good reasons to travel but
I just found breadth in Puzzles rather
than swaths of vast geography
fresh out of school well over a century
ago
I was mystified by what foolishness
governed public life
a dysfunctional Health Care System a
housing crisis Skies choked with
Wildfire smoke
funding for prisons exceeding funding
for education I had a long list of
complaints but whining wouldn't help
Society
so I pushed for reform
by becoming a Grassroots activist
but activism presented a new puzzle
better policies only work if politicians
Implement them
so I went into politics I got a seat on
the Board of Supervisors and then I went
on to become the mayor
finally I left City Hall and went back
to school to study Physics
at Lawrence Livermore I was working on
an early prototype of the fusion
reactors that power modern cities
including San Francisco
but to make real change
I needed money so I got into real estate
I bought a long dead Factory and tapping
my old Network at City Hall I converted
it into an open market with community
housing
yeah
we used self-healing bio bricks
carbon sucking cement
and mycelium fireproofing
then we leapfrogged into larger
developments attracting more creative
and economic energy into the city
there is the world as it is
and then there is the world you envision
activist polish politician scientist
entrepreneur investor
philanthropist
I'd been pushing the world to conform to
my vision for what it could become
I finally realized I needed to empower
others to invent their own future
and that's how I became what I am today
a teacher
Midway through walking the spiral
I kneel to push an errant Stone back
into place
high above a golden eagle
across the water San Francisco buzzes
with life
how many weddings
how many bursts
how many first kisses and New Beginnings
are taking place
as I take in this View
I push myself to my feet
and my joints complain bitterly
I don't blame them they spent way too
long above ground
if I were born today I'd read a list of
complaints as long as the one I wrote
when I was young
[Music]
we still live on the brink of apocalypse
environmental groups can't agree on
which extinct species to resurrect
how far back in the genetic code is
enough
new designer drugs hit the street daily
oh
some of them are extremely fun
but don't tell my students
I could go on forever but I won't
a friend once told me about a trip she'd
taken and one detail in her story stuck
with me
as the Drone left off the left off the
launch pad
the little boy in the seat behind her
screamed
yes
and everyone laughed
[Music]
and when they reached cruising altitude
and everyone went back to their
distractions
she realized that boy was the only one
who understood
how miraculous their flight really was
whenever life feels impossible
I just try to channel that little boy
I remind myself how incredible it is
that San Francisco became an archetype
of of urban reconsolidation
I reached the center of the Spiral
a spiral is the simplest form of
Labyrinth
to navigate a labyrinth
is to Quest Within
feeling whatever monsters are slumbering
in your heart
my thoughts spiral just like this path I
can't escape it even in dreams
worse every time I solve a puzzle it
reveals itself to be a piece of a much
larger puzzle
that is San Francisco
and puzzles like San Francisco can't be
solved
only reinvented
maybe that's the deepest problem of all
there is no Victory condition
no ultimate Triumph no end game
life can get infinitely better
while remaining endlessly
problematic
[Applause]
[Music]